this has been one of the most
controversial weeks in twitch's history
the story spans two years their
allegations of sexual assault and many
of the platform's biggest streamers have
weighed in on it here is the story in
full
[Music]
so everyone this video is just going to
be a summarize the events in full there
won't be room for much else so just
please follow along and as a warning to
you all I want to let you know this
video discusses sexual assault sexual
harassment as well as suicide so please
take care of yourself this story
actually begins in 2021 a streamer named
novu appeared on John Jerka stream and
ended up discussing why she felt creeped
out by another streamer crazy slick
people were saying that he was like
being really creepy at my birthday party
which made me feel responsible because
it was at my party and then recently in
January something happened where he's
like hitting on my 19 year old friend
which like had no business him talking
to like it was literally no business at
all and was like trying to get her to
take off her shirt and a call but like I
don't like I don't want to say these or
like my stories then on July 6th Adriana
Lee a variety streamer posted a twit
longer that said the following I was a
girl neru was talking about in the clip
on lsf on January 19th 2020 I went to
noru's 21st birthday party because I
went with of my closest friends I
believed it would be safe for me to
enjoy myself I got very intoxicated and
ended up blacked out leading the rest of
the story what I've heard from multiple
Witnesses and how I feel about it
apparently I was passed out in one of
the rooms at the party and he came into
the room while I was unconscious he came
to the room a couple of times after
being asked to leave me alone each time
in two of those instances he touched my
neck and chest saying he was just making
sure I was alive after being assured by
my friends that I was okay as they were
watching over me whether or not his
attentions were out of genuine concern
or not I don't know to be clear he did
not rape me or assault me but his
actions did make me uncomfortable crazy
slick wrote a twit longer addressing
this which we've got from a recent
Adriana Lee streams and Slick has since
deleted his Twitter he wrote I'm
incredibly sorry for making Adriana feel
uncomfortable at a party a year ago and
very sorry for her friends that night
for having to put up with me I was drunk
and anxious and my intentions were to
check her pulses because I was worried
crazy Slick's friend Ms Kiff and his
then girlfriend streamer Maya Higa what
went live to address the situation I
thought I was going to lose slick I
thought I would have to kick him out of
my house because I would not tolerate
any of that I just I'm not if if just
even though Slick's my best friend I
hang out with him literally every day uh
I'm not going to tolerate stuff like
that and I would totally kick him out of
the house because what I thought which
was the worst was that something
horrible happened we're
very grateful to Adriana for doing the
tweet that she did because she was
forced into that position and she talked
about her past experiences which is
super Brave and really really hard to do
he said that what did was inexcusable
and that's true because slick made
people uncomfortable even though it
wasn't his intention so he needs to take
accountability for that and he is taking
accountability for that the important
thing that she said in her statement and
the reason that slick is staying here
and having the opportunity to take that
accountability is because slick was
creepy and made people uncomfortable but
he did not assault anybody and he did
not rape anybody which I think a lot of
people made the assumption that he did
after the clip from novaru yesterday
after that the story completely faded
from the headlines people were aware of
the accusations but nothing came of it
recently though the story came back and
it stemmed from a completely separate
controversy on September 17th just last
week twitch content creator Slicker not
crazy slick was accused by multiple
people of scamming them out of money
allegedly for his gambling debts he went
live later that day and confirmed these
allegations the people that
I don't dirty
I'm really sorry I will try and keep
individually messaging you guys
I want to reach out to you guys and I'm
not asking for forgiveness I just want
to say
um you know I want to apologize Slicker
is alleged to have scammed hundreds of
thousands of dollars from people
including his own viewers this caused a
big discussion in the twitch Community
about whether or not gambling should be
allowed on Twitch since Flickr was using
the money to pay off gambling debts Miss
kid weighed in on the 18th saying like
if you think twitch should ban gambling
and hashtag twitch stop gambling on the
19th people we're still discussing the
shocking news of Slicker and his
gambling debts including Aspen gold who
tweeted how the [__] is slicker not
banned on Twitch guy literally uses the
platform to defraud dozens of people
streamers and viewers alike and admits
it Gideon is still sitting a Perma while
Slicker gets to go live and laugh about
actual crime it's an absolute disgrace
at twitch streamer train wreck replied
to this tweet saying because your Palace
decided it was in their best interest to
use and platform the very person that
scammed everyone for his horse racing
and Tennis bets to somehow twist it and
wager their war against me and we both
know deep down why the insecure little
man is doing this Miss Kiefer applied to
this in a now a deleted tweet saying if
we're going to de-platform people for
scamming others shouldn't we have banned
you for joltcoin a few years back
joltcoin is a cryptocurrency that train
wreck was linked to back in 2017. train
wreck responded to this by saying are
you going to send Maya and Mitch to
Railroad and blackmail me like you did
those girls to cover up all those sexual
assaults you [__] scumbag piece of
[__] you want to come at me and make
[__] up then you better be sure you
don't live in a glass house you insecure
and later follows up with a
clarification saying Ms Kiff didn't
assault the women he orchestrated the
cover-ups for his friends exactly how my
tweet reads so if you're having trouble
following Slicker got caught scamming
people for gambling money this prompted
miskief and others to advocate for the
Banning of gambling on Twitch and for
them to take action against Slicker and
in turn that caused train to accuse Miz
of covering up sexual assault Adriana
later on her stream confirmed that this
was in fact of her alleged experience
with crazy slick which we talked about
earlier in the video and from here on
we're now returning to talking about
crazy slick and the sexual assault
allegation we will not be talking about
Slicker and the scamming situation as
the story blew up controversial streamer
ice Poseidon then posted screenshots of
DMS between himself and Miss kid which
appear to show Miss Kip using racist and
homophobic slurs saying Miss Kiff I
brought you into this world and now I'm
taking you out a clip also resurfaced
from September 2021 a Miss Kiff talking
about Adriana Lee's alleged experience
in downplaying the entire situation I
mean like who like no one of what you
can deem of it it's sexual harassment
whatever
at a low scale it's not really a big
deal
I don't think people really gave and
really cared yeah I'm gonna turn this
off if you're gonna be like this I'll
just turn it off my he get one live to
explain how she interacted with Adriana
after the incident was slick we all
thought that
that we're gonna that slick was gonna be
you know gonna have to move out and and
that everything was ending slick was my
best friend at the time
I went over to try to figure out what
happened I wanted to clear up what
happened and I asked if she could
include that it wasn't Raper sexual
assault because at the time she said
that it wasn't
um but she wanted to share that it made
her uncomfortable and she wanted to
share her story she did from what I can
tell Adriana had actually Gone live
right before that stream to tell her
side of the story it is a two hour long
stream but I watched it and Adriana
addresses everything and more it is a
public VOD that I encourage you to
co-watch for any details that we don't
cover here here I will be doing my best
to summarize the points she made and I
apologize for looking at my screen but
there is lots to cover at the very
beginning of her stream she played a
clip of Miss Kiff talking about the
situation I I will pretty much say it
he harassed that girl
he did uh
and and you know I he needs to get
better he needs to do better it's it's
it's wrong it's it's [__] wrong I I
really think he has a lot to work on man
Adriana expressed on stream that she is
a survivor of sexual assault from before
all of this she said the craziest like
incident occurred when she was 19 years
old she explained how she passed out and
fell asleep after drinking at a party
she said slick came into the room as she
was passed out to check in on her by
checking her pulse but was doing so on
her chest and was told by people to stop
doing so this allegedly happened
multiple times this clip I'm about to
show you was from something she recorded
before talking about the situation I was
drunk and then I passed out because I
drink too much but I was like it was
like in an Airbnb so I was just in a
room and then he kept like trying to
come in like feel my chest and like
touch my boob and my friend was like yo
stop I'm just checking her post she's
like dude stop you're not checking your
post and then he would go away and he
would come back and try and do it again
so my friends literally had to guard me
and uh the craziest part is it's not
just like oh accusation he admitted this
he admitted to doing this like he put
out his twit laundry after mine saying
oh I'm so sorry Adriana Adriana
explained throughout the entire stream
that after novaru brought up the
situation Adriana wanted to speak about
it allegedly Maya Berry and Mitch came
over to Adriana's place to speak about
how she should handle the situation
publicly Adriana said that Maya told her
to write nothing at all or to do it
anonymously she also said she was made
to downplay what allegedly happened was
slick and to push the focus on to Nova
for bringing all of this up in this clip
she called a friend who was there to
corroborate what allegedly happened when
she passed out and the twitlonger
process they came over
uh you know to our house came over like
you know we're so sorry this happened
you know blah blah we want to we want to
make sure you know you know this is
handled correctly because you know what
you do stop we typed out your Tweet or
took longer or what you know whatever we
were doing but they wanted to proofread
it yeah and have it all through it to
not make a theme as extreme or live
stream we're just like not as bad as it
was you know try not paint the image as
you know that
you know that he wasn't such a bad guy
earlier in the Stream Adriano played a
clip where she described coming to an
agreement with Maya because Maya
allegedly said we don't want to kick him
out Maya was like um I just don't think
you should say anything at all and I'm
like are you [__] kidding me I like
or she said I should say something
anonymously or everyone was like no or
or I should say it wasn't that big of a
deal and I'm over right now and I was
like listen I'm gonna be true to myself
I'll make this like look good like like
an angel because I did in the Tweet
longer if anybody ever bothered to read
it because a lot of people didn't
um I makes like look like an angel I'm
like hey
it's whatever this may be uncomfortable
but it's whatever even though I was
upset with it I just you know
I came to a even point with Maya because
Maya was like we don't want to kick him
out so I was like okay whatever Adriana
said towards the end of the stream that
she is not sure if Maya tried to get her
to downplay what happened or Miss gift
told Maya to downplay it Adriana had
said earlier in the Stream though that
she was told by someone that Miss Kiff
sent Maya over to Adriana because it
would look better and convince her not
to get slick kicked out I was told that
Ms sent the most credible nicest girl on
Twitch to talk to me instead of him
going over there
because it would look better it'd be
better to convince me not to not to get
slick kicked out she later dressed
Mitch's involvement after the twitlonger
was posted Adriana said he apologized
for how everything went down and his
conduct she also stated that the only
reason Trey knows about the situation is
because of Mitch multiple times on her
stream she expressed how grateful she
was for a train wreck for coming forward
with this information explain how train
has had her back which she supported in
a later tweet Adriana also spoke about
how this entire situation has affected
her career her friendships and her
mental health and I saw right in front
of my eyes that people that I thought
were my friends leave
disregard our friendship for clout
because it made
people slick uncomfortable it's like Ms
whatever to be around me
and it [__] hurt and yeah obviously
there's a lot of instances where it's
like wow I could have been in that
stream I could have selled my career
that way but what hurt the most is the
people that I called my [__] friends
my best [__] friends turn on me
because their career was more important
she said after this clip that she was
quote blacklisted from events and things
were harder for me to grow as a twitch
streamer additionally throughout her
entire stream she described ways slick
would attempt to scare me or intimidate
me whether it be approaching her friends
or going to a party he was not invited
to she said earlier in the Stream that
she actually had gone up to slick to ask
him to stop talking [__] and being
excluded she said that she heard slick
spread rumors that she would sleep with
people in Austin Adriana also claimed
that slick told her friends that she has
apologized but she refuted and said she
probably apologized for everything
happening for asking him to stop talking
[__] since the day of this stream
Adriana Lee has been signal boosting the
stories of people's alleged interactions
was slick she also did this on her
stream where she describes slick sending
sexual messages to multiple women so now
we are done with the 19th of September
Now we move on to the 20th Dex Center
reported on the 20th that slick
according to miss Kiff appeared to be
missing and had sent a farewell message
to his friends on the same day otk
released a statement that Miss give had
been placed on Lee pending investigation
and minutes later Ms kit posted his
statement on all of this he addressed
everything starting out with slick being
accounted for and safe he apologized for
the statements made on stream about the
alleged situation and the DMS that night
Adriana went live again with a stream
entitled why am I not in the call where
she live reacted to Hassan xqc train
wrecking Pokemon all discussing her
situation and she was confused as to why
they were discussing it when she was not
in the call during the second stream
Adriana was eventually added to the call
and was able to relay her feelings about
what was being discussed she explained
to everyone why exactly this was the
best time to discuss what had allegedly
happened I mean I've witnessed it I've
lived through it the last time that I
came out about this thing it was kind of
like oh my gosh like you're valid your
feelings are valid like you're so strong
for coming out about this and then boom
Oh my God crazy slick lover host oh my
God crazy slick me and Alcova it's like
at the end of the day it felt like God
damn like
sorry I'm not a tick tock guy because
Sienna May is getting a lot of heat for
touching someone when they're
unconscious in and apparently my abuser
can just run free
so I under what they're trying to say is
that the timing of this no matter how
weird you guys think it was it had to be
played out this way because if it was
any other way people can sit there and
they can say oh well we're here for you
oh well this is a situation because
that's what they said in June 2021
everyone want to sit there and virtue
signal and pretend that they were there
for me and and pretend that they were
doing the right thing and then two
months later when it was in the clear
everything just reverted back to normal
and you can hear so in The Miz clip
where he says everyone who still who
didn't hung out with us like still hangs
out with him blah blah blah and then you
could also see so in my thread of girls
who are continued continuously got
sexually harassed of numbers of them by
Slick there had been some animosity
beforehand with the likes of Hassan and
Pokeman who were accused of being
dismissive of the news Adriana discussed
the importance of taking sexual assault
seriously and Pokey as well as Hassan
apologized for their respective
reactions Adriana also spoke about how
painful was to suffer in silence the
past year and defended train wreck one
again on this stream xcc and Trainwreck
described a call that's meant to relay
Adriana's story to necessary parties
without having Adriana involved because
obviously there was going to be denying
there was going to be you know this and
that invalidated so there were there
were mutual parties brought in that were
going to mediate it and Asthma gold was
one of them
since he was a part of otk there was a
bias there xcc was there
and some of the information was relayed
Barry was there Mitch was there Barry
and Mitch were both in the house when
everything happened all their
information was relayed
and that's what was discussed this is a
later addition to the story but
apparently on September 22nd YouTube
streamer Destiny somehow got access to a
recording of that call I've not been
able to listen to it in its entirety but
allegedly Barry who you will remember
was said to be present with Maya Mitch
when they came over discussed what he
saw as Maya's conduct it was basically
my gaslighting Adriana the whole time
basically saying are you sure this is
what slicked to you you're pretty drunk
you wouldn't remember it are you sure
that doesn't sound something like slick
would do we know slick and then she was
like if you tweet longer Crazy slick
this won't be good for your streaming
career you won't yeah the very small
bits and pieces I've been able to listen
to of this call allegedly she'll miss
Kiff admitting to sending Maya over I
didn't go because you know why I didn't
go I knew that if I went trained it
would have looked immediately like a
power play because it would have if I
went there and I was sitting there at
you know 30k Andy against these people
it's going to look like a power play and
it's going to look bad
is because Maya is much more liked
people respect her and I I feel like
Maya can talk to these girls because I
want to know what the [__] went on with
my best friend another late addition to
this story is what Mitch claims about
miskip's intentions of sending them over
did Ms
explicitly give direction to you and
Maya and whoever the [__] else was in
that room to go to Adriana's house
into quote unquote
downplay the situation or find a way to
save slake's ass yes or no the answer to
that is yes after leaving the call of
Pokemon and others Adriana went back to
Hershey and discussed the call the
alleged situation and sexual assault as
a whole she discussed why it's important
for the twitch Community not to sweep
these situations under the rug these
things come out they're they're on top
of lsf for a week and then people forget
about them
and then the victims are sit there have
to sit there and live
their trauma every single day
and watch their abusers prance free and
go on love or hosts and and joke around
with their current friends
you know I think that this happens so
much in the community the latter part of
the stream was quite emotional and
intense as Adriana herself interviewers
shared their stories of sexual assault
with both parties offering support to
each other she also reacted to miss kids
twitlogger which I mentioned earlier
which her friend told her he allegedly
had to post four different times because
he had spelled her name wrong in
addition to apologizing for his use of
slurs he wrote that in terms of his
living situation slick has been told to
vacate our house as soon as possible I
appreciate and support those who are
brave enough to come forward with their
stories about his behavior a little
while after Slick's misconduct came to
light last year I made some inexcusable
statements on a altstream after some
chat messages got to me to Adriana and
all those affected by sexual harassment
I am sorry for those statements sexual
harassment regardless of degree can
never be considered small and while my
intention was to clarify a misleading
chat message I chose my words poorly and
my response came off as downplaying
which should never be downplayed Adriana
mentioned how misgift had reached out to
her as well as Maya although she had not
read Maya's message yet she spoke
towards the very end about how she
hadn't actually realized what had
happened to her by Slick was sexual
assault and she hadn't known that he had
touched her chest until the day she
wrote the twit longer and so far that
has been the end of the situation
regarding train wreck Ms Kiff crazy
slick and Adriana Lee I know he spoke
about Slicker and gambling earlier and
twitch recently made a statement about
the future of gambling on their platform
to my colleague Josh has made a video on
that was released yesterday which I
recommend all of you check out two
important things if you are somebody you
know has a gambling problem and wants
help resources are available where you
live you can follow the link in the
description to visit the National
Council on problem gambling to find out
more second thing no survivors of sexual
harassment or assault owe you their
story and you have no right to come
forward with a story that is not yours
survivors owe you absolutely nothing
survivors should never have their career
or relationships be harmed because of
their bravery to share their story and
just because it wasn't rape doesn't mean
it wasn't upsetting or traumatizing
Survivor stories should never be
minimized because of the subjective
severity of the situation there are
resources for survivors of sexual
assault I will leave in the description
if you're a Survivor you are not at
fault you are not alone and there is
help for you available I am one person
telling a summarization of Adriana's
story you owe it to her to listen to her
Talent
[Music]
[Laughter]